Pulitzer prize-winning historian Doris
Kearns Goodwin has made a career out of
studying American presidents she's
returning to her favorite subjects in a
new book leadership in turbulent times
it's published by Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS the book focuses on
Abraham Lincoln Theodore Roosevelt
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and Lyndon
Baines Johnson it highlights their
efforts to unite the country in tough
times
President Johnson tried to do that when
he lobbied Congress to pass the Voting
Rights Act in 1965 there is no southern
problem there is no northern problem
there is only an American problem great
to see you thank you so I want to start
with the quality of empathy you talk
about leadership but empathy is all
through this book and when we think of
leadership leaders we think of people
charging up the hill empathise a softer
quality but it a lot of the men in this
book had it I think it's a central
leadership quality I mean what it means
is being able to understand another
person's point of view to actually feel
their circumstances several of my guys
had it from birth I think I call them my
god I think Lincoln was born with it
even as a little kid he hated when his
fellow friends would put hot coals on
Turtles to make them regal anyone said
that's wrong you're causing pain
I think LBJ in some ways because he was
born in that poverty circumstances had
it but the other two privileged guys had
to develop it over time and Teddy
Roosevelt said when he first went into
politics he went in for an adventure not
to make other people's lives better but
then he saw what it was like in the
tenements he saw child labor he saw
things when he was a police commissioner
on the street and he suddenly decided if
I'm in politics maybe I can make other
people's lives better I can feel what
they're feeling and self-conscious at
first but then it becomes part of who
you are and he said it changed his heart
it did changed its heart you I want to
talk about your fireside chats or your
guys fireside chat President Roosevelt
because that was a direct connection to
the voters to the people do you see any
comparison at all between Donald Trump's
Twitter account is that a direct
connection can we make a
comparison between the two well it is
certainly a direct connection but the
difference is the fireside chats took
place over maybe 45 minutes for an hour
they explained our oblems to the people
he was speaking directly to each
individual it's wonderful they said Saul
Bellow could walk down the street on a
hot Chicago night when one of the
fireside chats was on the air you could
see everybody looking at their radio in
their kitchen or their living hear his
voice coming out and keep walking and
not miss a word of what he was saying
everybody was listening and he was able
to make a direct connection to the
person in the living room there's a
construction worker who ran home one
night partner said where are you going
he said my president he's coming to
speak to me in my living room but it's
only right I Phoenix the direct
connection doors yes but what they did
was to explain a problem in depth I mean
for example when the banking crisis
occurred when FDR first came into office
people are taking their money from the
banks he fixed it so that the currency
would be shoring up the weaker banks he
says I promise you it's safer to bring
your money back they opened the banks
again they worried will they take even
more out satchels come and they're
bringing money back because they trusted
him they acted on his word for something
that was going to save the system as a
whole as opposed to what President Trump
I'm trying to figure out the difference
between the two well I think what the
what the president is doing with his
tweets is they come extemporaneously
they're not as prepared Roosevelt used
to spend weeks preparing each one of
those fireside chats he didn't want to
say something that would hurt not the
right word he went over them five or six
times because he knew a president has a
dignity has a moment to speak to the
press to the people and it has to be
right well let me ask you because it
seems that historians have becomes
people therapists these days and you
constantly get asked have we seen times
like this before where there's so much
divisiveness in the country and
sometimes from the President himself
have we absolutely we've seen worse
terms and I do feel like I can history
can help us just imagine what it was
like for Abraham Lincoln he comes into
office the country is already split into
more than 600,000 people are about to
die
he later said if he'd ever imagined how
anxious it would be he couldn't have
thought he lived through it even Teddy
Roosevelt when he comes in after the
assassination of McKinley the country is
split apart worse than it is now by the
Industrial Revolution the working class
feels absolutely split off from the
capitalist this immigrants coming in
from abroad there's a gap between the
rich and the poor
is a fear that there's going to be a
revolution among working people and of
course when FDR comes in the depression
is at its height you can't get your
money out of the banks there's no jobs
and even JFK coming in JFK's
assassination bringing LBJ in when they
thought of a conspiracy so we lived
through those times before it's what
called them to their greatness Doris
Kearns Goodwin thank you so much for
being with us leadership in turbulent
times is available now and it is
fantastic